a través de la televisión nacional el
presidente de mali brain bubacar keita
anunció su renuncia un giro en la crisis
política del país y eleva la
incertidumbre sobre el destino en la
nación africana
[Música]
de la inversión al pueblo
quisiera en este momento agradecer al
pueblo maliense por su apoyo y
acompañarme durante estos últimos años
un día lo decidió
y he decidido renunciar a mis funciones
de manera inmediata esto también
significa que el gobierno y la asamblea
nacional se disolverán
proyecto que consideramos delgado
[Música]
la distribución de la sombra nacional
es el domingo la emisión de keita llega
después que un grupo de militares lo
detuviera junto a otros funcionarios
entre ellos el ministro de finanzas y el
primer ministro de la nación miles de
personas se aglomeraron en la plaza de
la independencia de bamako para expresar
su apoyo a los militares todo el pueblo
de malí estaba esperando este día todo
el pueblo de malí estaba esperando que
calla magán y sus hombres al menos nos
dejaran respirar el tutorial del deber
al sur todo mal y ha sido liberado por
una fuerza republicana el pueblo de malí
los apoya
estamos felices no hay educación no hay
salud no hay seguridad se le ha dicho y
no quiere escuchar a su gente el
levantamiento genera un cambio en un
país afectado desde hace dos meses por
protestas contra el gobierno los
manifestantes exigían la renuncia de
keita a quien responsabilizan de una
economía estancada la corrupción en el
gobierno y una insurgencia yihadista